Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we are going to talk about a new endeavor
to teach some more common sense to learning
algorithms.
If you remember, in an earlier episode, we
talked about an excellent work by Andrej Karpathy,
who built an algorithm that looked at an input
image, and described, in a full, well-formed
sentence what is depicted there.
By the way, he recently became director of
AI at Tesla.
Before that, he worked at OpenAI, freshly
after graduating with a PhD.
Now that is a scholarly career if I've ever
seen one!
Reading about this earlier work was one of
those moments when I really had to hold on
to my papers not to fall out of the chair,
but of course, as it should be with every
new breakthrough, the failure cases were thoroughly
discussed.
One of the the motivations for this new work
is that we could improve the results by creating
a video database that contains a ton of commonly
occurring events that would be useful to learn.
These events include, moving and picking up,
or holding, poking, throwing, pouring, or
plugging in different things, and much more.
The goal is that these neural algorithms would
get tons of training data for these, and would
be able to distinguish whether a human is
showing them something, or just moving things
about.
The already existing video databases are surprisingly
sparse in this sort of information, and in
this new, freshly published dataset, we can
learn on a 100.000 labeled videos to accelerate
research in this direction.
I love how many these works are intertwined
and how followup research works try to address
the weaknesses of previous techniques.
Some initial results with learning on this
dataset are also reported to kick things off,
and they seem quite good if you look at the
results here, but since this was not the focus
of the paper, we shouldn't expect superhuman
performance.
However, as almost all papers in research
are stepping stones, two more followup papers
down the line, this will be an entirely different
discussion.
I'd love to report back to you on the progress
later.
Super excited for that.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time.